[Musique]
pour les soldats de la seconde guerre
mondiale rien n'est plus terrifiant que
de tomber entre les griffes de l'est
s'ajoutant aux conditions de détention
déshumanisante
cette pub irrépressible va engendrer
certains des événements les plus
fascinants de la guerre
[Musique]
voici la véritable histoire derrière le
célèbre film la grande évasion
comment les combattants de la résistance
échapper à la torture et les exécutions
comment de nombreux aviateurs descendu
en vol loin derrière le gymnase y
parviennent à s'arracher leur captivité
comment de leur côté des allemands
réussissent à s'enfuir des camps de
prisonniers aux états unis ces récits
authentiques et remarquable font tous
partie des grandes évasions de la
seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
en europe la bataille qui se joue dans
les airs et son ex
[Musique]
les alliés et les allemands se dispute
âprement la maîtrise du ciel le nombre
d'appareils abattu en vol deux pilotes
tués ou capturés est énorme
[Musique]
pendant les premières années du conflit
l'angleterre qui fait cavalier seul voix
celle en décimer la probabilité pour
qu'un aviateurs britanniques s'en
sortent sains et saufs est alors
inférieur à 50%
[Musique]
en 1941 les américains s'engagent à leur
tour dans le conflit les combats
s'intensifient et avec eux les pertes en
1945 plus de cent cinquante mille
soldats alliés de l'armée de l'air ont
été tués
pour les quelques heureux survivants à
la chute de leur appareil la descente en
territoire ennemi marque le début d'une
nouvelle vie
[Musique]
si certains échappe miraculeusement à la
capture bien souvent grâce à l'aide de
la résistance
la grande majorité tombe aussitôt entre
les mains de l'ennemi
[Musique]
j'ai atterri près d'une ferme et j'ai
demandé aux propriétaires s'ils savaient
où se trouvaient les allemands ils sont
pointés du doigt une porte et m'ont dit
il y en a trois le sort de ces quarante
cinq mille aviateurs alliés pris par les
allemands est terrifiant ils deviennent
brusquement prisonniers de guerre et
sont conduits vers un camp de détention
d'asie
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés d'un seul coup dans
un lieu où il n'y avait eu ni nourriture
ni livre ni liberté ni quoi que ce soit
à écouter pour se distraire c'était
assez déprimant vous savez je pense que
satiné l'être humain n'a pas envie qu'on
le mette en cage
quand vous arrivez là bas pour la
première fois vous voyez tous ces
pauvres gars qui errent dans le camp la
première chose que vous vous demandez
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne se sont
pas échappés
vous comprenez nous arrivés là dedans
avec votre liberté et d'un seul coup
vous prenez conscience que vous allez
devoir affronter une toute nouvelle
expérience
il ya un type là haut dans un mirador
avec un pistolet-mitrailleur qui vous
surveille
et là vous réalisez que vous avez perdu
votre liberté qu'elle a disparu
ça fait un sacré choc je peux vous le
dire et vous devez faire avec tout le
monde n'a pas réagi de la même manière
certains sont devenus complètement fou
dès qu'ils sont arrivés au camp
beaucoup trouvent cette nouvelle vie
insupportable il se l'est alors obsédée
par une seule et même idée s'échapper
certains vivaient en rêvant uniquement
d'évasion la façon la plus directe de sa
bd était d'escalader la clôture
quelques-uns en ont d'ailleurs eu
l'audace je crois pour ma part que
c'était au delà de mes capacités mais en
revanche la seule méthode donner
l'impression qu'elle pourrait
fonctionner et qu'on avait des chances
de s'en sortir vivants
c'était de creuser au camp de
prisonniers de guerre de l'air force
appelée le stalag luft un avare en
allemagne une centaine de tunnels ont
été creusés par les prisonniers peuls
ont abouti les captifs se décourage
jamais et continuent de tenter leur
chance
selon la convention de genève il est en
effet du devoir des officiers d'essayer
de s'évader afin d'entraver l'effort de
guerre de l'ennemi
les gardes allemands l'ont bien compris
aussi en essayant de s'enfuir
risque-t-on tout au plus la plupart du
temps de se faire réprimander et de se
voir enfermé une dizaine de jours au
frais je pense que s'il était
effectivement pénible de rester tout
seul dix jours dans un trou en ce qui
nous concerne nous nous retrouvions
toujours à six ou huit dans la même
pièce
on avait la paix pendant ta maman ce
n'était pas vraiment ce qu'on pouvait
appeler une épreuve
en 1942 les camps de prisonniers en
allemagne sont pleins à craquer
d'aviateurs alliés capturés en mission
en avril on décide donc d'ouvrir un
nouveau et gigantesque complexe
pénitentiaire asa gagnent en pologne à
environ 160 kilomètres au sud est de
berlin en peu de temps
pas moins de dix mille officiers
britanniques canadiens et américains de
l'air force se retrouvent ainsi reclus
au stalag luft 3 tenant compte des
expériences passées
le camp est un modèle du genre en
matière de surveillance de prévention d
évasion le stalag luft 3 est réputé pour
être en quelque sorte un quartier de
haute sécurité
[Musique]
on a construit ce qu'en dehors des
forêts profondes à des dizaines de
kilomètres les territoires neutre sur un
sol volontairement sablonneux la surface
elle est en terre battue mais juste en
dessous c'était du sable qui s'enfonçait
à des profondeurs inimaginable les
allemands étaient convaincus qu'avec ça
on ne pourrait jamais s'enfuir il était
loin de s'imaginer qu'on parviendrait
malgré tout à creuser des tunnels
malgré ce type d'obstacle c'est bien au
stalag luft 3 que la tristement célèbre
grande évasion aura lieu
une évasion particulièrement audacieuse
monté par une organisation impliquant
plus de 600 hommes aux compétences
variées des ingénieurs qui vont creuser
trois imposants tunnel à 9 mètres de
profondeur avec des ateliers ainsi qu'un
mini train souterrain un réseau
incroyablement astucieux de faussaires
le cartographe de fabricants de boussole
de tayer de machinistes d'agents de
renseignement et de sécurité
si le fameux film de 1963 immortalise
cette opération de grande envergure sa
réalité est bien plus fascinante que
n'importe quel scénariste hollywoodien
n'aurait osé l'imaginer
la chose la plus surprenante n'est pas
tant qu'on y soit arrivé mais qu'on y
soit arrivé sans que les allemands s'en
aperçoive
l'ironie du sort veut que le stalag
l'oof3 constituent l'environnement idéal
au développement d'une telle
organisation
[Musique]
adolf hitler a en effet confié le
commandement de la luftwaffe l'aviation
militaire allemande assure maréchal
hermann goering
celui ci est un homme égotiste et
puissant à l'origine de la gestapo et
des premiers camps de concentration une
part des responsabilités de la luftwaffe
consiste précisément en lagarde les
prisonniers de l'air force une
perspective effrayante pour les alliés
cependant gearing est un as de
l'aviation de la première guerre
mondiale
il éprouve du respect pour les aviateurs
quel qu'il soit aussi c'est dans un faux
élan de générosité qu'il a décidé que le
stalag luft 3 ne serait pas encore de
concentration mais un camp de
prisonniers jimmy james a été capturé
dix mois seulement après le début de la
guerre il a subi l'épreuve de saint
calais de détention dans ces camps
réservé à l'air force
nous étions traités en général à sumène
mans il n'y avait aucun risque pour nous
de finir en camp de concentration
les camps de concentration étaient
tenues par les ss les sections spéciales
d'hitler alors que les camps de
prisonniers étaient gérés par du
personnel militaire en ce qui nous
concerne par la luftwaffe
on s'est d'ailleurs bien entendu avec
une partie de ce personnel je crois
qu'on a eu beaucoup de chance de se
retrouver dans un conte de ce type en
particulier au stalag l'oof3 on nous
avait dit que c'était le fin du fin pour
les prisonniers de l'air force
je pense que l'idée des allemands était
que le camp soit suffisamment
confortable pour qu'il n'y ait aucun
trouble possible nous resterions assis
là tranquillement jusqu'à ce qu'il gagne
la guerre bien entendu ils se sont
trompés
[Musique]
en vérité les baraquements sont
surchargés et les rations insuffisante
mais le véritable combat de cette vie
carcérale ce livre contre l'ennui
insoutenable et contre la perte même de
la dignité et de la liberté
[Musique]
en mai 1940 days nelly est abattu en vol
est fait prisonnier lui aussi passé cinq
années extrêmement difficiles en
captivité
les allemands ne nous donnait qu'un
repas par jour mais la soupe ainsi qu'un
morceau de pain qui je crois nous durer
trois jours
le soir on jouait aux cartes on espérait
l on se parlait les uns les autres en
essayant de se remémorer le goût que
pouvait avoir un bon 10 steaks et ce
genre de choses
avant la guerre john cornwell et
d'architectes afin de tenir le coup
moralement il dessine le journal de sa
vie quotidienne en prison ce journal de
bord d'étang de guerre constitue un
témoignage remarquable sur la vie au
stalag luft 3
[Musique]
il fallait s'occuper l'esprit s'efforcer
de penser à autre chose
il fallait voir vers l'avenir ne pas
oublier qu'une autre vie nous attendait
après celle ci
chacun s'occupe comme il peut
les américains jouent au baseball
elle égale à 10 ans ok
[Musique]
on essaie de se maintenir en forme il
faut garder ses muscles pour le cas où
une chance se présenterait
certains choisissent de poursuivre leurs
études
d'autres de s'engager dans l'orchestré
du camp mais tout le monde sans
exception à la nostalgie du pays
mis à part les femmes je pense que ce
qui nous manquait le plus c'était notre
liberté
au fur et à mesure que le temps passait
on voyait arriver d'autres amis ils se
mettaient à nous parler de leur vie de
ceux qui avaient changé pour nous
c'était un monde si lointain de ce qu'on
vivait nous mêmes nous avions vraiment
le sentiment que la vie nous passer à
côté dick churchill est un passionné de
musique il parvient à obtenir des
allemands de pouvoir utiliser un
gramophone
j'ai commencé avec deux coffrets de
disques l'un était sa sixième symphonie
appelé la pathétique
l'autre était casse noisette
avec ses amis il adresse des lettres
dans le monde entier demandant qu'on
leur envoie d'autres albums à la fin de
la guerre ils devront ainsi hamas est
venue de 3010
et
en nous plongeant dans la musique on
arrivait à faire en sorte que nos
conditions de vie s'estompe un peu et
passe à l'arrière-plan
au printemps 1943 les allemands laissent
les prisonniers bâtir leur propre
théâtre les détenus met en scène des
spectacles élaborés ou certains des
comédiens improvisent et incarne même le
rôle de femme
[Musique]
c'était une sacrée terapeak de faire du
théâtre
croyez moi aller au théâtre revenait à
sortir pour assister à un événement
extraordinaire
on n'essayait même de se cuisiner pour
l'occasion à dîner qui sortent un peu de
l'ordinaire
c'était une chose qu'on avait
pratiquement élevé au rang de raison de
vivre le théâtre faisait également
partie de la philosophie des allemands
laissons les prisonniers faire leur truc
au moins ça les occupe et pendant ce
temps là ils ne pensent pas à s'enfuir
malheureusement pour eux on avait beau
être occupés on n'avait pas pour autant
tirer un trait sur l'espoir de nous car
à pattes et de cet endroit s'évader
reste pour beaucoup de prisonniers de
guerre le but à terre il refuse
d'admettre le principe selon lequel
personne ne peut s'échapper du stalag
love 2 3 les tentatives d'évasion sont
constantes et deviennent presque un
nouveau sport permettant de garder
l'esprit en alerte
[Musique]
c'était une manière d'exercer notre
droit qui était aussi un devoir pour bon
nombre d'entre nous on pouvait presque
appeler ça un jeu il s'agissait de voir
si l'on était capable de berner les
minutes
la plupart des tentatives sont vouées à
l'échec les gardiens spécialement
entraînés que les prisonniers appellent
eux-mêmes les furets parviennent à les
déjouer presque tout
[Musique]
les prisonniers de guerre comprennent
que s'ils veulent réaliser leur rêve il
leur faut s'organiser s'est rangé mais
seul un chef d'escadron vers l'afrique
du sud et brillant avocat en angleterre
avant la guerre qui va présider à la
destinée d'un groupe baptisé
l'organisation x un groupe chargé
d'organiser l'évasion en question le
seul a été placé au stalag louf de 3
après quatre tentatives d'évasion
d'autres quand on avait tous confiance
en roger rochelle parce qu'on
connaissait ses activités passées il est
naturellement devenu big x
le grand chef de l'organisation x et
nous nous sommes mis très logiquement à
suivre ses ordres
sydney dose est l'un des voisins de
chambrée de busher il devient son
confident
[Musique]
m le but de roger était de faire sortir
200 officiers en même temps par un même
tunnel il disait que ce type d'opération
serait de taille à faire dérailler la
machine de guerre allemande
mars 1943 le projet de brûler lancé
toute l'année plus de 600 hommes
courageux vous consacrer le moindre
instant de leur vie à un seul et unique
but la grande évasion
[Musique]
l'organisation x a désormais pris le
contrôle de tout ce qui peut toucher à
une évasion du stalag 9 2 3 toute autre
tentative que celles fixées doit aussi
obtenir l'aval du groupe
rien ne sera tolérée qui puisse
compromettre la grande évasion
au centre du projet de chaîne il ya la
construction simultanée de trois tunnels
au nom de code de tom dieck et harry
enfin jusque là dans notre camp comme
dans les autres il n'avait été question
que d'un seul tunnel à la fois que les
allemands découvrent l ouvrage
il fallait tout recommencer depuis le
début j'imagine donc que roger a pensé
en construire trois en même temps
de sorte que si l'un était découvert on
puisse se rabattre sur les autres le
colonel albert car qu un lieutenant
américain devient big s chef de la
sécurité
il est chargé entre autres de réunir les
sommes capables de mener à bien le
projet on a commencé par les interroger
pour s'assurer que c'était de véritables
prisonniers de guerre et non pas des
taupes envoyés par les allemandes
on a essayé ensuite de savoir de quelle
formation il avait pu bénéficier et
quelles étaient les compétences dont il
disposait et qui pouvait coller à nos
besoins
d'ailleurs pas une seule fois on s'est
trouvés en manque deux gars capable
d'accomplir des tâches précises
le canadien où aller flou des et chargé
de superviser le creusement des tunnels
dans le civil il a été ingénieur des
mines
ce n'est pas lui qui rendra les galeries
très étroite les tunnels dépasseront à
peine 60 cm de côté et descendu si
souvent dans les mines que ça ne le
dérangeait pas plus que ça beaucoup de
gens se sentait terriblement
claustrophobe et d'autres devaient
apprendre à gérer ça mais wali n'ai
jamais ressenti le besoin de s'adapter
la construction démarre le 11 avril 1943
c'est un projet de très grande envergure
les furets ayant planté des appareils
d'écouté électronique dans le sol on est
obligés de creuser à plus de 9 mètres de
profondeur
pour arriver de l'autre côté de la
clôture il faut dépasser la longueur
d'un terrain de football avec un
sous-sol aussi sablonneux le moindre
centimètre de galeries doit être étayé à
l'aide de planches les lattes qui
supporte les matelas à l'intérieur des
couchettes vont parfaitement la faire
lorsqu'ils ont ouvert ce camp les
allemands commis une regrettable erreur
celle d'équipé les couchettes de
sommiers complet d'ailleurs quand le
tunnel a été terminé les gars ont passé
du temps à bricoler leur lit avec du
câble des torchons de la ficelle pour
faire tenir leur matelas parce que les
planches avaient été utilisés dans les
tunnels afin d'évacuer les énormes
quantités de terre et le sable on
construit un système souterrain de
chariots sur rails ceux ci supporte
jusqu'à 90 kg de déblais certes
également acheminé les ouvriers au fond
l'air frais fait rapidement défaut on
fabrique une pompe à air à partir de
sacs à dos
[Musique]
celui ci est transmis à travers un tuyau
fait de boîtes de lait
sous terre on progresse lentement
environ un mètre vingt par jour les
mineurs travail par équipe de 2 à l'aide
d'outils rudimentaires façonnés à la
main
la peur de l'effondrement est permanente
[Musique]
ken reese est l'un des principaux
mineurs il ne connaît que trop bien les
dangers du terrassement
[Musique]
le pire était lorsque vous croisiez trop
loin de quelques dizaines de centimètres
ça commençait à s'effondrer et ça
risquait de vous ensevelir le copain
derrière vous était heureusement là pour
vous tiré de justesse en arrière
problème c'était que vous étiez dans le
noir total
vu que votre petite lampe à huile avait
été elle aussi recouverte par le sable
tout ça a été effectivement assez
effrayant l'organisation x sait par
expérience qu'une évasion ne peut
réussir sur l'appui d'une équipe
complète en surface
[Musique]
le plus gros problème reste de se voir
où évacuer le sable creuser les furets
ont supprimé leurs bords les plateformes
supportant les baraquements
on ne veut donc plus rien écoulée en
dessous de plus le sable extrait est
d'un jaune très clair on risque de le
remarquer
on trouve la solution en confectionnant
des sacs à partir de serviettes de
toilette que l'on dissimulé sous ses
vêtements
les prisonniers ont obtenu la permission
de cultiver de petits jardins les
équipes de dispersion du sable appelé
les pingouins répandent minutieusement
le sable à travers ses jardins pendant
que d'autres camarades se charge de
l'état les pour le mélanger à la terre
en décembre 43 nos pingouins ont
dispersées en tout 110 8 tonnes de
déblais tout ça en vingt-cinq mille
trajet et pour les trois tunnels
la sécurité fait également partie des
composantes essentielles de la réussite
du plan
le secret absolu doit être gardé on ne
parlait jamais des tunnels s'il arrivait
qu'on entende quelqu'un les évoquer on
lui sauter dessus pour le faire taire
mais les simples mots de tunnels sable
etc étaient proscrits de cette manière
on gardait toutes nos chances pour que
les allemands ne soit au courant de rien
trois cents hommes surnommés les
complices surveille constamment les
furets
au moindre danger ils transmettent un
signal d' alerte vers les baraquements
où les opérations ont lieu
il a bien sûr fallu dissimulé l'entrée
des tunnels en creux ce tome de manière
pratiquement invisible depuis un seul
bétonné dick démarre pratiquement sous
l'eau dans un bassin de drainage situé
sous les douches et harry est caché sous
un poids
[Musique]
les évadés auront évidemment besoin de
papier le passeport une fois libre les
faussaires partent donc travailler vers
une salle de classe déguisé en étudiant
pendant que les complices surveille les
parages les documents qu'ils fabriquent
se révèle être d'une précision et la
détails extraordinaires en tant qu
architecte on m'a chargé d'imiter à la
main des caractères tapés à la machine
on dessine est tous très minutieusement
à l'aide d'un crayon très fin ensuite on
repassait deux fois par dessus avec de
l'aquarelle et avec un bâton à la pointe
effilée ont découpé le papier en vente
leur faisait même en sorte qu'elle peut
fois qu'une lettre particulière soit
décalé vous savez comme sur une machine
à écrire défectueuses ou une lettre des
rails c'était un travail de fou et le
résultat ressemblait à s'y méprendre un
document authentique
la position de cachet officiel sculptées
dans des talents de bottes met la touche
finale à ses faux documents
afin de pouvoir se repérer une fois
dehors les quatre graves ont fabriqué
mille cartes détaillées en quatre
couleurs
on confectionne également deux sans
boussole à partir de lames de rasoir et
des disques ne dicte cacher
[Musique]
les disquettes est fait à partir d'un
composé de cire
il servait à former la surface non
métalliques d'une boussole et on les
chauffer et on en prélevait des lamelles
qu'on moulay ensuite par exemple sur les
hauts-parleurs que les allemands avaient
placé dans plusieurs blocs pour diffuser
leur propagande
en fouillant vraiment ils auraient pu
retrouver un tas des grilles de boussole
collé à l'arrière de la partie est monté
à l'intérieur du haut parleurs les
services de renseignement se charge de
recueillir des informations capitales
ainsi que des accessoires extrêmement
importants comme les horaires de trains
ou des appareils photographiques pour
les pièces d'identité il soudoie les
gardiens et les font chanter grâce aux
objets que les prisonniers reçoivent de
chez eux
j'ai pu envoyer quatre colis par an la
population allemande n'avait pas du tout
ce dont on disposait ici ainsi mes fils
ont pu échanger certains biens comme du
chocolat ou du café qu'on ne trouvait
pas en allemagne et que les gardiens
souhaitait absolument rapporter chez eux
quand ils partaient en permission
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu les corons
une fois que d'obtenir un allemand qui
avait accepté un pot de vin
c'est par le coude que vous le traîniez
s'il ne fournissait pas les informations
voulues il suffisait de le faire chanter
en le prévenant qu'on allait le dénoncer
pour tel autre information qu'il avait
déjà livré cela suffisait à la fois nous
assurer qu'il ne dirai rien sur nous et
qu'il continuerait à nous renseigner le
canadien qui sont élevées à travailler
avec le service de renseignement afin de
trouver des documents officiels à
reproduire un jour le vieux sergent
allemand qui s'occupait de notre groupe
me tournait le dos avec son portefeuille
qui dépassait de sa poche arrière et
j'ai délicatement tiré sur le
portefeuille
je les passais à l'un des gars en lui
disant d'amener ça à roger et de leur
apporter aussi vite que possible
on a donc photographié tous ses papiers
quand notre copain nous a rapporté le
portefeuille
on a tapé sur l'épaule du vieux en lui
disant hey regardez on a retrouvé votre
portefeuille par terre le type s'est
pratiquement évanoui oh mon dieu si je
perds ça c'est le front de l'est assuré
pour moi je suis tellement content
tellement contents ils ne savaient plus
quoi faire pour nous remercier
à partir des uniformes des prisonniers
de leur couverture les tailleurs
confectionne des tenues de civils on y
rajoute des poches cacher pour y
dissimuler la nourriture pour le trajet
on va même jusqu'à équiper deux futurs
fugitif d'uniformes allemands fait
maison
on avait habillé l'un de nos camarades
en sergent allemand on lui avait
fabriqué un fusil à partir de pièces de
bois et à moins de prendre larmes pour
l'examiner de plus près il était
impossible de la différencier d'une
vraie jusqu'à la fin août 1943
on continue de creuser au nez et à la
barbe des allemands
cependant l'organisation a remarqué que
l'on construisait un nouvel ensemble de
baraquements il s'agit en fait de
déplacer d'ici quelques mois les
prisonniers américains dont nombre
d'entre eux ont travaillé dur sur
l'étude elle et personne ne veut les
voir rater leur change de s'enfuir
[Musique]
on décide alors de concentrer ses
efforts sur tom le tunnel le plus court
on cesse de creuser harry et dick sert à
évacuer le sable il faut mettre les
bouchées doubles si l'on veut s'évader
avant que le nouveau complexe ne soit
terminée
les furets suspecte bien quelque chose
mais la sécurité si bien assurer qu'ils
sont incapables de trouver la moindre
preuve
[Musique]
à la mi septembre
tom est pratiquement terminée certains
les prisonniers pense même qu'ils
passeront noël en famille mais le rêve
tourne court un furet découvre tout à
fait par hasard
l'entrée du tunnel ils étaient en train
de discuter et l'un des gardiens jouait
plus ou moins en même temps avec un long
pitt de fer qui tapotaient contre le sol
le pic a fini par fissurer la trappe et
par la traversée
l'allemand a tout de suite compris de
quoi il s'agissait
voilà on avait enfin trouvé ce qui se
tramait
nous étions tous tristes parce que ça
aurait été une super d'évasion on était
déjà à au moins six mètres à l'intérieur
des bois et on aurait pu faire passer
200 hommes sans aucun problème cette
découverte est pour eux un choc terrible
les américains viennent de perdre leur
champ de s'évader
les furets ont remporté une manche mais
roger michel avait prévu cette
possibilité
l organisation dispose encore de deux
tunnels
[Musique]
les furets redoublent désormais de
vigilance aussi pendant quatre mois on
cesse toute activité de terrassement en
espérant qu'ils finiront par relâcher
leur attention
finalement en janvier 1944
les terrassiers redescendre les neuf
mètres du puits de harry et se remettent
à creuser
il a été décidé de se concentrer sur
harry si c'est le plus long trajet
jusqu'à la clôture
les allemands seront justement loin de
se douter qu'on puisse engager un tel
projet
mais l'hiver qui s'est installée rend la
dispersion du sable beaucoup plus
difficile quand on a repris à riz qu'on
ne pouvait évidemment pas se permettre
de répandre à même la neige le sable
creuser alors on s'est demandé ce qu'on
pouvait en faire à une réunion du comité
quelqu'un a proposé et pourquoi pas le
théâtre et la roja büchel a répondu
sacrée bonne idée
le théâtre ou s'avère être un lieu idéal
les prisonniers l'eau construit de leurs
propres mains ils ont laissé les bords
du soubassement fermés il y à là plein
de place on construit donc une trappe
sous l'un des sièges
on a dispersé énormément de sable de
cette manière chaque soir pendant
environ deux mois
à la fin ça devait faire 80 tonnes de
sable glisser là dessous le 14 mars 1944
le tunnel
harry a enfin atteint la longueur prévue
plus de 100 m
[Musique]
après presque une année de travail
l'évasion est quasiment prête
mais l'hiver est toujours aussi rudes le
comité préfèrerait attendre que le
printemps ce soin d'installer la
sécurité répond qu'elle ne peut pas
tenir plus longtemps si l'on s'en fut
maintenant le gel rendre à la cavale
beaucoup plus difficile mais on
déstabilisera bien davantage l'effort de
guerre allemand
on arrête donc la date du 24 mars 1944
comme celle du moment fatidique
l'une des raisons était que c'était une
nuit sans lune
il fallait aussi fixer une échéance de
manière à ce que tous les laissez-passer
soient tamponnés à la même date le
comité de l'organisation doit encore
affronter la lourde responsabilité de
choisir quels sont les 200 hommes qui
s'enfuit un tir haut j'ai d é lui même
les 30 premiers les plus susceptibles de
rejoindre leur pays et leur foyer en
particulier grâce à leur pratique
courante de l'allemand on tire au sort
dans un chapeau les 170 suivant je crois
que c'était vers la mi mars
un gars du comité est entré et m'a
annoncé que mon nom avait été tiré au
sort pour faire partie d'un groupe qui
traverserait le tunnel j'étais bien sûr
très heureux pensez-vous donc après
trois années à ruminer cette perspective
je n'avais jamais rien gagné auparavant
à la loterie et là c'était en quelque
sorte le gros lot les deux sens heureux
élus reçoivent en même temps que leurs
nouveaux papiers l'identité des
vêtements ainsi que de l'argent et leur
assure de nourriture pour la route
il est alors plus question de revenir en
arrière
on sentait bien tout à coup une
excitation envahir le camp c'était en
même temps dangereux et difficile à
vivre parce que les hommes voulaient se
parler les uns les autres
vous savez les moins expérimentés sur la
question voulez en apprendre de leurs
camarades qui avait déjà tenté
l'expérience il voulait tout savoir d'un
coup avoir les meilleurs conseils
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comment
fait-on où il faut aller ensuite on
sentait beaucoup d'anxiété
je pense que tout le monde ressentirait
d'une manière ou d'une autre de
l'inquiétude dans ce type de situation
mais ce qui primait c'était le fait
qu'on ait enfin une chance de sortir de
là on avait gratté le sol pendant des
années en se contentant d'espérer et le
rêve allait enfin devenir réalité
les allemands sont convaincus qu'une
évasion se trame
mais ils ne parviennent toujours pas à
en obtenir la preuve
cependant on voit wali flou dit est ce
que d'autres membres clés de
l'organisation x brusquement transférés
vers d'autres camps une mesure qui
s'assortit d'un avertissement général
comme quoi s'évader ne sera désormais
plus considérés comme un sport peu en
réalité y prête attention
lors de nos toutes dernières réunions
avec roger
nous avons discuté de la sortie du
tunnel il nous a fait un topo sur ce à
quoi on pouvait s'attendre de l'autre
côté sur ce qui pouvait nous arriver et
ne pas nous arriver
je me souviens parfaitement avoir dit
que les [__] étaient des petits malins
qui finas il vous plaque contre un mur
et vous menace de vous abattre
j'ai ajouté qu'il n'oserait jamais faire
ça
[Musique]
nous sommes au soir du 24 mars point
culminant d'années de labeur et
d'intenses préparatifs
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée
la première équipe s'enfonce comme prévu
dans le tunnel mais elle se heurte
bientôt au premier d'une malencontreuse
série d'obstacles
l'une des choses les plus importantes
que nous ayons oublié était qu'il y
avait énormément de neige par terre et
qu en dessous c'était de la glace on
n'avait pas prévu que la glace
recouvrirait notre trappe de sortie dans
les bois et l'on n'avait pas non plus
d'objets pour faire office de pic à
glace
on a perdu comme ça une heure et demie
je crois qu'on devait sortir vers 20h30
21h en réalité la première personne a
mis le nez dehors à 22h30
en passant la tête à l'air libre les
hommes découvrent avec effroi qu'ils
sont encore à 9 mètres de la bordure des
bois roger décide rapidement d'un plan
le premier rang prat jusqu aux arbres il
se cachera dans les buissons et
signalera au suivant par une corde que
la voie est libre
d'autres hommes sont à présent engager
dans le tunnel de 60 cm de côté beaucoup
s'y trouve pour la toute première fois
la chose n'était pas difficile pour ceux
qu'ils avaient creusé il avait eu le
temps de s'y habituer mais vous imaginez
la différence pour ceux qui ne l'avaient
jamais vu auparavant il était tout à
coup confronté à cet étroit passage qui
disparaissait au loin un ou deux gars
ont d'ailleurs été pris de panique
certains ont voulu emporter trop de
choses avec eux il heurte les planches
qui était la galerie corps au camp de
nombreux affaissement qui ajoute encore
aux retards les gens me demandent
parfois
qu'avez vous fait pendant que vous étiez
allongé dans le tunnel on est resté
allongé comme ça à trois quarts d'heure
environ à attendre que devant il répare
le haut du tunnel alors je leur répond
simplement je suis resté allongé vous
rendre la progression plus facile on a
tiré une ligne d'éclairage à partir de
câbles volés et branché sur
l'électricité du baraquement mai vers
minuit un raid aérien sur berlin
occasionne une coupure de courant
retardant encore l'évasion de 35 minutes
la progression est lente mais les hommes
atteignent peu à peu les extrémités du
tunnel
[Musique]
bombay si j'avais pu j'en aurais hurlé
de joie je me retrouvais tout à coup de
l'autre côté de la clôture
même si ça ne devait être que pour un
court instant
c'était en tout cas la liberté
c'était comme avoir tout à coup entre
les mains un grand whisky soda sous
terre on continue de se démener de
ramper vers la liberté dans tout à coup
une sentinelle s'éloigne de son poste de
garde et se rapproche dangereusement de
la sortie du tunnel
qu'elle continue d'avancer tout est
perdu
[Musique]
à 4h55 du matin soixante ces sommes sont
déjà sortis mais une sentinelle s'avance
dangereusement vers la trappe des
tunnels j'étais le numéro 76 je me
trouvait allongé au sol
regardant d'un côté vers le tunnel de
l'autre vers le garde qui n'arrêtait pas
de se rapprocher je me disais mon dieu
pourvu qu'ils cessent d'avancer comme ça
pourvu qu'il revienne sur ses pas mais
il a continué de marcher jusqu'à ce
qu'il se retrouve pratiquement à
l'aplomb du trou celui qui était juste
en dessous et qui attendait pour faire
sa sortie a bondi alors vers les arbres
à partir de là je crois que ça a été la
débandade
la sentinelle tirs alors que kim jong il
vit s'enfuit dans les bois
je m'étais lancé à mon tour dans le
tunnel devait en être à la moitié du
parcours
quand j'ai entendu un coup de feu je ne
pouvais pas tourner dans l'autre sens
alors j'ai rebroussé chemin à reculons
et je suis remonté dans le baraquement
où c'était un véritable bazar tout le
monde brûle et ses papiers et se gaver
de rations qui avaient été distribués
pour la fuite
parce qu'on savait que ça allait nous
être confisqué les gars s'empiffrait de
leurs barres de chocolat
au stalag l'oof3 les gardiens découvrent
rapidement les preuves à charge qui leur
manquait lé alerte générale est lancée
sur tout le territoire allemand
quoi qu'il arrive dorénavant la grande
évasion a d'ores et déjà atteint l'un de
ses principaux objectifs plus de 5
millions d'allemands sont en effet
démobilisés de l'effort de guerre et
doivent participer à la traque des
fugitifs
[Musique]
les évadés sont maintenant rendus à leur
liberté beaucoup comme dit churchill et
keith odile vie traverse à pied les
interminables forêt gelé espérant
pouvoir parcourir les 160 km qui les
séparent de la frontière mais ils sont
bientôt trahi par le mauvais temps
les sommes que les allemands rattrapions
d'épuiser est gelé d'autres fugitifs
comme s'ils des dolls jimmy james et des
snle se risque à prendre le train mais
sous l'oeil inquisiteur des allemands il
ne tarde pas à être démasqué on m'a
interrogé dans le train et je pensais
m'en sortir plutôt bien
en vérité je me suis fait prendre j'ai
demandé alors où est ce que j'avais eu
faux et l'on m'a avoué que ce qui
m'avait trahie n'était pas ce que
j'avais répondu j'avais été
effectivement convaincant mais c'était
la faute aux prises en tenue d'évasion
on m'a dit comme ça vous portez sur
cette photo exactement la même chemise
et la même cravate que celle que vous
avez là et ce ne sont pas des choses
qu'on rencontre dans la réalité
sur les 76 évadé d'une elle seule 3
retrouveront leur liberté
l'un d'entre eux rejoint la hollande
dans le train pendant que les deux
autres sautent à bord d'un cargo suède
doit on rassemble les hommes et on les
met sous les verrous la plupart s'étant
retourné au stalag l'oof3 et a passé un
bon bout de temps aux frais mais ses
tentatives est différente des
précédentes
hitler lui même a été informée de
l'évasion massive il est furieux
il donne l'ordre à la gestapo d'abattre
la totalité des prisonniers
goering parvient néanmoins à convaincre
le führer qu'une telle décision
risquerait de déclencher des
représailles de la part des alliés
contre les prisonniers allemands
on décide alors que 50 fugitif seront
exécutés
la gestapo est venu à notre prison ils
ont emmené des petits groupes de 6 8 ou
10 hommes qu'on n'a jamais revu on ne
savait pas où il était passé
nice qui avait pu leur arriver
l'hypothèse optimiste voulais qu'ils
étaient simplement reconduit au camp est
en vérité c'est vers leur propre mort
qu'on les a menés on ramène chaque
groupe vers le stalag l'oof3 par la
route pendant le trajet les voitures
s'arrêtent et l'andorre le prisonnier de
descendre se dégourdir les jambes et le
moment choisi pour qu'un agent de la
gestapo s'avance dans leur dos elle
retire dans la nuque
personne ne sait exactement sur quels
critères on a choisi les 50 condamné à
mort aucune logique de guider cette
décision roger beuchat n'a été exécutée
à la queen's des officiers de la royal
air force a été épargné la plupart des
23 fugitif survivants retourne au stalag
l'oof3 là on les informe officiellement
de l'horrible nouvelle nous a envoyé un
officier qui nous a annoncé que 50
d'entre nous avaient été touchés dans
leur fuite
mais je note l'officier s'est ensuite
dirigé vers l'officier allemand pour lui
demander combien parmi eux avaient été
blessés
l'allemand s'est alors tourné vers nous
avec des larmes dans les yeux pour nous
lire le rapport officiel comme quoi on
avait abattu 50 hommes qui avaient tenté
de s'enfuir
c'était la phrase en usage pour
camoufler un assassinat
plusieurs semaines plus tard on remet
aux prisonniers les urnes contenant les
cendres des victimes les survivants du
massacre obtiennent l'autorisation
d'ériger un monument à la mémoire de
leurs camarades tombés au champ
d'honneur
[Musique]
on était tous abattus ça n'était pas que
si quelqu'un avait joué les têtes
brûlées en essayant par exemple
d'escalader la clôture en plein jour et
s'était fait prendre par une sentinelle
ce genre de choses pouvaient
effectivement faire partie des risques
de la guerre mais assassiné de
sang-froid 50 fichiers était un acte
absolument inconcevable
admettre que ces faits avait bien eu
lieu nous a été extrêmement difficile
à la fin il nous a bien fallu nous
rendre à l'évidence
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs avait au
moins un ami sinon plusieurs parmi ces
50 camarades
malgré toute leur horreur de la chose
les tentatives d'évasion se poursuivre
alors que la guerre se termine on creuse
à nouveau tunnel du nom de georges jim
james
si des doses et wings des sont envoyés
vers un corps de la mort là ils ont à
nouveau creusés mais seront une nouvelle
fois rattrapé
un an plus tard les alliés libère les
camps d'emprisonnement dans un ultime et
glorieux geste de défi les derniers
détenus met le feu au bâtiment avant de
s'apprêter à retrouver leur liberté
ils ont survécu même s'ils ont dû
laisser entre les mains de l'ennemi des
années de leur jeunesse
d'autres cependant ont eu plus de chance
en parvenant à échapper aux nazis à
l'intérieur des lignes ennemies
[Musique]
sabotage terrorisme espionnage
assassinat c'est le rôle de la
résistance dans l'europe occupée de la
seconde guerre mondiale ou comment de
courage civil hommes et femmes mènent
une guerre secrète contre l'occupant
nazi
moment ils interviennent derrière les
lignes ennemies afin d'appuyer les
alliés et reconquérir la dignité et la
liberté volée à leur pays dans leur
action les résistants savent qu'ils
risquent gros est repris par les
allemands c'est être torturées puis
exécutées
[Musique]
l'une de leurs principales missions
consistent à aider les aviateurs alliés
descendu en vol à fuir le sol animés
afin de les abriter et de les guider en
sécurité vers leur rapatriement
la résistance a élaboré un réseau
complexe de communication d'agent secret
et de refuge
ces filières clandestines spécialisé
dans les évasions portent des noms de
code le réseau comète
le réseau o'leary le réseau opossum mais
aussi efficace et organisé soit elle la
liberté n'est souvent pour ces soldats
alliés que l'aboutissement d'un long
périple
les aviateurs ont en effet à parcourir à
pied des centaines de kilomètres en
territoire ennemi avant d'espérer
rejoindre un pays neutre dès 1940
winston churchill reconnaît lui-même
l'importance de cette lutte clandestine
il crée une division des opérations
spéciales une partie de cette section se
compose d'une unité depuis le chevronné
appelé escadrille 161 à qui l'on confie
des responsabilités pas régulier
leur mission consiste à voler loin
derrière les lignes afin de parachuté à
la résistance nourriture équipement
armes et munitions ainsi que les agents
des forces spéciales
c'est l'une des artères qui alimentent
en vivre la résistance et nous permet
d'entretenir ces filières d'évasion
afin également de récupérer leurs
compatriotes 161 pilotes se poseront à
maintes occasions dans des champs et
despréz anonyme
après un vol périlleux guidé par la
seule clarté de la lune
s'ils savent que les dangers qu'ils
affrontent sur d'immenses il ne reste
pas moins fermement engagée dans leur
mission en 1943 hengbart iti un ancien
pilote spécialisé dans la chasse
aériennes nocturnes se portent
volontaires pour rejoindre cet espace
rond en 1942
j'étais déjà père de deux enfants l'idée
qu'ils puissent se retrouver sous la
domination des nazis m'était
insupportable on accepte on devait donc
faire tout ce qui était dans nos moyens
pour empêcher ça en club
le pilote lewis odj fait partie de cette
escadrille 161
il se souvient de l'extrême importance
des opérations nous suit envol dans le
nord de la france il a miraculeusement
réussi à marcher sur 1300 km avant de
rejoindre la frontière espagnole
je me rappelle parfaitement ma traversée
à pied des pyrénées
je me disais que si seulement un avion
pouvait arriver et atterrit rien que
pour moi dans le champ juste en face
tout serait merveilleux je ne me rendais
pas compte que pendant 18 mois c'est
exactement ce que j'avais fait en
compagnie de mon escadrille mais le
succès de ces opérations aériennes ne
repose pas uniquement sur le courage et
la dextérité des pilotes
les agents français chargés de repérer
et de préparer les champs pour chaque
atterrissage remplissent un rôle tout
aussi important il fallait premièrement
un prêt qu'ils fassent environ 1 km de
long et qu'on puisse facilement protéger
en postant des gars de tout autour
l'artilleur aérien fred gardner fait
partie de ceux qui ont eu la chance
d'être secourue grâce aux efforts
extraordinaires de l'escadrille 161
en 1943 il est à son poste à bord d'un
bombardier lancaster quand son appareil
est touché au dessus de la belgique
les mézières schmitt allemands nous ont
attaqués on s'est fait descendre en
flammes et par chance on a réussi à s'en
sortir
sauf trois camarades qui se sont fait
tuer
dans sa chute garner a perdu ses
chaussures il se pose dans un champ
il fait nuit noire l'a enveloppé dans
son parachute
il attend le jour au petit matin il
commence à chercher alentour s'il veut
trouver de l'aide
j'avais très mal au pied
au bout d'un moment je suis arrivé dans
un petit village en descendant la rue
principale
j'ai entendu que des véhicules de
transport approchait et je me suis dit
que ça pouvait bien être des allemands
la population n'avait pas encore
énormément de véhicules à moteur à
l'époque je me suis donc précipité pour
entrer dans la première maison qui se
trouvait là et heureusement parce qu'en
regardant par la fenêtre j'ai vu passer
un camion militaire allemand qui
transportait des soldats avec leurs
fusils debout entre les genoux je suis
sûr qu'il parte à notre recherche
après le crash de notre langue casters
cette maison il y avait une vieille dame
qui a éclaté en sanglots lorsqu'elle ma
ville je ne sais pas si c'est parce
qu'elle avait peur ou bien si c'était
mon apparence qui l'attristait il faut
dire que j'étais assez amoché
j'avais un oeil poché des cheveux brûlés
j'étais pieds nus j'étais couvert
d'ecchymoses
elle a appelé un homme qui était dans
une autre pièce
il m'a apporté des chaussures et des
vêtements en me recommandant de me
mettre immédiatement civile j'ai compris
à ce moment là que j'avais eu la bonne
intuition de tomber sur cette maison est
sûre ces gens si gentil qui allait
peut-être même m'aider à quitter le pays
en escale
le lendemain on donne à gardner une
bicyclette et on l'accompagné jusqu'au
village suivant à 5 km je commençais à
désespérer de pouvoir récupérer du
sommeil il y avait là un beau lit bien
confortable je venais juste de me
déshabiller de mai glisser sous les
draps quand un type a fait irruption
pour me dire de partir sur le champ avec
lui parce que j'étais dans la maison
d'un collaborateur
dès lors il se retrouve sous la
protectrice de la résistance
mais les résistants doivent tant
qu'homme s'assurer qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un imposteur un de leurs agents
l'interrogent à l'heure ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'il m'a donné un grand
coup de poing pour observer ma réaction
je pense que si je m'étais exclamé en
allemand plutôt qu'en anglais on
m'aurait pris pour une taupe allemande
et ce en aurait été fini pour moi
le soir même on emmène gardner au
presbytère du village où le prêtre les
berges
le lendemain soir celui ci lui remet une
soutane comme nouvel habit il le conduit
ensuite vers un lieu convenu et après
avoir échangé une série le sifflement
codé le confie un nouveau résistants
ce résistant avait échappé à une
embuscade des allemands ils étaient
fichés et la gestapo le traquer le fait
de me retrouver avec lui ne facilitez
donc pas les choses
les deux hommes traversent prudemment
les bois mais soudain il tombe sur un
camp militaire allemand
on était près d'un baraquement et tout à
coup une porte s'est ouverte en laissant
passer de la lumière vers nous des
soldats allemands sont sortis par
grappes avec leurs fusils et mon
compagnon m'a aussitôt poussé dans un
fossé
on a attendu la croupi pendant que les
allemands enfourché leur bicyclette
ils sont passés juste à côté de nous là
j'ai réalisé que si on avait fait le
moindre bruit comme éternuer ou tousser
et s'il s'en était rendu compte mon
compagnon aurait probablement tiré et
son aurait été fini de nous deux gardner
ne sait pas encore qui vient d'être pris
en charge par les réseaux opossum chargé
de le faire passer en espagne pendant
deux semaines on le conduit parmi les
dédales de l'organisation secrète pas
une fois il connaîtra la véritable
identité de ses bienfaiteurs ni les
destinations vers lesquelles on leben
tous les gens impliqués dans cette
chaîne d'entr'aide d'un village à
l'autre et d'une maison à l'autre risque
est bien sûr leur vie pour moi j'étais
tout à fait conscient que si on les
attrape et ça pouvait être la mort pour
eux alors que pour ma part j'aurais pu
m'en tirer avec le statut de prisonnier
de guerre
on fournit à gardner une fausse identité
il s'appellera désormais jean joseph
jacques
un taxi l'emmène au prix d'une
résistante qui l'accompagnent à travers
la forêt jusqu'à la frontière franco
belge
là un autre guide le prendre avec une
autre personne il est conduit tous deux
à la gare de sedan le guide leur a
ordonné de l'attendre à la table d'un
restaurant pendant qu'ils achètent des
billets le train tout à coup des soldats
allemands sont venus s'asseoir à la même
table
ils ont posé leur pistolet mitrailleur
par terre contre le banc qu il ne
fallait pas qu'on prononce le moindre
mot en sortant de la gare
notre guide qui avait compris la
situation nous a fait signe de nous
équipe s'est discrètement
la chance lui a à nouveau sourit après
un voyage quelque peu tendu il descend
ares
il est en territoire ennemi depuis plus
d'un mois à présent pourtant s'il s'en
est miraculeusement bien tirée jusque là
il se trouve encore à plus de 800
kilomètres de la frontière espagnole où
la liberté là dedans
l'étape suivante est en lieu sûr dans la
petite ville de fismes ou une famille le
prend sous sa protection
c'est chez eux qu'on nous a annoncé
qu'on allait peut-être sortir de france
grâce à un avion qui devait arriver avec
des agents et un chargement destiné à la
résistance j'ai appris la nouvelle avec
un de ses bonheurs
après plusieurs fausses alertes garner
apprend enfin qu'un vol est prévu pour
le 13 septembre
on lui demande de se tenir prêts à
partir pour 23h20 marché dans
l'obscurité jusqu'aux champs où devait
avoir lieu l'atterrissage on nous avait
demandé de rester complètement
silencieux et de marché l'un derrière
l'autre en gardant une certaine distance
entre nous en approchant du terrain on a
vu l'appareil arrivé au dessus de nos
têtes
soit il était en avance soit c'est nous
qui étions en retard
le pilote qui attend au tournant au
dessus du champ n'est autre que hugues
varité le délai fixé tire à sa fin
s'il ne reçoit pas sous quelques
instants le signal prévu il sera
contraint d'abandonner ma mission
[Musique]
effectué des cercles au dessus pas
exactement au dessus du champ mais je
revenais régulièrement pour voir s'il
était enfin arrivé j'ai attendu comme ça
environ une heure
on a couru sur les 400 derniers mètres
qui nous séparait de la piste
d'atterrissage
il a fallu encore allumé les torches
après un dernier tour le pilote a
effectué sa descente
pendant qu'on nous demandait de
patienter à l'abri il a fait un très bon
atterrissage
et puis un demi tour vers le début de la
piste de manière à se tenir prêts à
décoller quelques minutes plus tard on
s'élever dans les airs pour rentrer chez
nous on a traversé la manche puis on a
survolé la côte anglaise où j'ai reconnu
l'endroit où vivait ma grand-mère et
même sa rue elle n'avait plus de
nouvelles de moi depuis plusieurs
semaines elle ne savait pas que j'étais
vivant elle croyait peut-être même que
j'étais mort
après cinq semaines de cavale on ramène
fred gardner sain et sauf en angleterre
mais parmi ceux qui l'ont aidé tous
n'ont pas eu autant de chance
certains de ceux qui l'ont hébergée à
fismes jusqu'à son vol de rapatriement
mourront en déportation
après avoir été dénoncé par leur propre
fille à la gestapo
tu as l'agent responsable de l'opération
un belge du nom de dominique portier
peintre malheureusement après quelques
opérations comme celle ci il a été trahi
on l'a attrapé et on la torture est
tellement qu'il n'en pouvait plus et il
a préféré mettre fin à ses jours en
sautant par une fenêtre du deuxième
étage
à la fin de la guerre
l'escadron de la lune aura ici rapatrié
plus de 650 passagers hors de la france
occupée
plus de 6000 aviateurs alliés sont
également parvenus à échapper à leur
arrestation
si derrière chacun de ces hommes se
cachent des événements dramatiques
aucun récit d'évasion mais aussi
audacieux et palpitant que l'histoire
vécue par lucie et raymond aubrac
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée du
conflit les actions de la résistance
s'intensifie
les résistants reste en permanence
confrontés au spectre de la brutalité et
de la torture nazis ils savent que s'ils
sont pris ils mourront
[Musique]
barbara bertram et son mari ont des
bergers en lieu sûr chez eux dans le sud
de l'angleterre
des agents de renseignement français en
route vers leur pays occupé plus de 200
agents sont assis passer par leur
domicile parmi eux une femme qui lui a
raconté les pratiques des lasi elle m'a
raconté les tortures elle m'a dit que
beaucoup de gens étaient d'accord avec
elle pour penser que les petites choses
étaient les pires comme le fait
d'arracher des dents ou bien les ongles
ou encore d'enfoncer des épingles dans
la poitrine
c'est et pire encore et plus
insupportable que les coûts et le
supplice de la baignoire
malgré les dangers terrifiant qui les
guettent les réseaux de résistants se
multiplient
en 1941 lucie et raymond aubrac
participe à la fondation du groupe
libération sud à lyon
ils ont déjà un bébé jean-pierre et
lucie est enceinte de leur deuxième
enfant elle est enseignante lui est
ingénieur se servant de cette vie
quelque peu anonyme comme d'une
couverture ils parviennent à organiser
sans trop d'inquiétude les réunions à
leur domicile avenue esquirol bien que
le début de la guerre comptent de
nombreux groupes de résistants comme
celui des aubrac ceux ci restent
dispersées manque encore d'organisations
le principal artisan de l'unification de
ses réseaux sous la bannière du général
de gaulle n'est autre que jean moulin en
raymond et lucie aubrac leur encontre
moulin confié raymond le commandement de
l'armée secrète pour le nord de la
france
[Musique]
ce fut pour moi une fierté
je me trouvais hisser au plus haut
sommet cette seule et unique rencontre
avec jean moulin d'importants duré que
deux heures nous avons échangé une
poignée de main au début et une autre
poignée de main lorsque nous nous sommes
quittés en nous disant revoir et à
demain et il n'y a jamais eu de
lendemain
le 21 juin raymond a rendez vous avec
jean moulin au domicile du docteur
frédéric dugoujon un éminent médecin
proche de la résistance
[Musique]
quand tout à coup sa maison je trouve
encerclé par une troupe d'éléments de la
gestapo sous les ordres de leur
tristement célèbre chef klaus barbie
qu'ils nous ont tous arrêté la gestapo a
fait irruption de la manière la plus
brutale qui soit
ils sont montés au deuxième étage et ont
commencé à casser les meubles et a
frappé tout le monde
après quoi ils nous ont passé les
menottes et jean moulin qui se trouvait
juste à côté de moi à ce moment là ma
demande et d'attraper discrètement un
papier dans sa poche et de m'en
débarrasser
je les mange et le goût n'était pas
terrible
on emmène les prisonniers au sous-sol du
quartier général de la gestapo
ils sont interrogés de jour et passent
leurs nuits dans leurs dribbles prison
dumont l'udc
l'uci et son groupe savent parfaitement
que ces interrogatoires s'accompagne de
torture ils s'affairent immédiatement à
monter un plan pour libérer les hommes
[Musique]
comme a dit sa soeur jean moulin est l
homme qui connaissait tous les chefs de
réseau il était le seul à connaître tous
les lieux clandestins de réunions que la
police n'avait pas encore découvert
c'était donc lui qu'il fallait
absolument libéré en premier mais la
gestapo questionne jean moulin de la
manière la plus expéditive et violente
qui soient un jour raymond aubrac
aperçoit son supérieur par un trou à
travers la porte de sa cellule
c'est par ce petit trou dans la porte de
ma cellule que j'ai vu jean moulin pour
la toute dernière fois
deux soldats l'emmenait poursuivre son
interrogatoire en bas il était couvert
de sang
ses vêtements étaient maculés est
déchiré moulin à payer le prix des rib
l'an gardant le silence complet
il est trop tard pour le sauver mais
l'on peut encore faire quelque chose
pour raymond le 23 juin
son épouse se met sur son 31 elle emmène
avec elle de faux papiers d'identité et
se rend au quartier général de la
gestapo en se présentant comme sa
fiancée
curieusement barbie en personne accepte
de la recevoir
elle le supplie alors de libérer raymond
mais barbie ne plie pas lui même
d'ailleurs qui chaque jour depuis une
semaine
s'occupe de l'interrogatoire et des
sévices sur son mari
il prenait une matraque
ils me frappaient dans le dos et sur la
tête en répétant sans cesse les mêmes
questions et je me suis d'ailleurs
évanoui au cours de ses interrogatoires
mais raymond lui aussi reste muet la
gestapo ne s'est même pas aperçu qu'il
était juif
néanmoins son sort est joué et lucie
c'est que les minutes qui lui reste pour
agir sont comptés avec son réseau elle
élabore un plan audacieux
si elle peut s'arranger pour le voir au
quartier général de la gestapo ses
camarades seront à quel moment précis on
leur conduira vers la prison
ils tenteront alors une embuscade aux
camions sur le chemin du retour
tous se lancent avec ferveur dans les
préparatifs et les répétitions
la soeur de lucie se charge de placer
provisoirement le petit jean pierre
auprès d'un home d'enfants dans le
massif du vercors sa mère peut ainsi se
concentrer à plein temps sur le projet
d'évasion
lucie achète deux allemands pour qu'il
lui permette de voir raymond
elle les a convaincus qu'il devait
absolument voir son fiancé afin de lui
demander de l'épouser avant son
exécution pour la dignité de l'enfant
qu'elle porte en elle at elle déclaré
le 19 septembre on ramène raymond au
quartier général de la gestapo
lorsqu'il entre dans le bureau lucie s'y
trouvent déjà
alors pendant un instant j'ai pensé
évidemment qu'elle était arrêtée
et puis j'ai vu qu'elle portait un
superbe chapeau ainsi qu'une nouvelle
robe
l'officier de la gestapo été très
courtois avec elle et j'ai réalisé à ce
moment-là qu'il était en train de se
passer quelque chose d'inhabituel
l'uci est convaincante dans son rôle de
sciences et amoureuse éperdue
la gestapo marche lorsqu'elle lui lance
un clin d'oeil d'adieu raymond comprends
qu'on prépare son évasion
pour mener à bien la muscade
on a fait passer en contrebande des
armes depuis la suisse chaque détail de
l'opération a été réglé avec le plus
grand soin le réseau de l'uci est enfin
prêt
donc on a attendu le retour de ce camion
le soir dans les rues de lyon
et quand il est arrivé à 18h30
on a attaqué son chauffeur ainsi que
deux soldats allemands
l'un à côté et l'autre derrière on avait
des armes munies de silencieux
les soldats de la gestapo savent qu'en
cas d' embuscade
ils doivent abattre immédiatement la
totalité des prisonniers qu'ils
transportent les que lucie attaqué le
camion les officier qui nous
accompagnaient ont hésité à nous tuer au
lieu de ça ils ont sauté du camion pour
tirer sur nos camarades avec les autres
prisonniers on en a profité pour
s'enfuir
on a été trop vite et j'ai reçu une
balle dans la joue que je n'ai pas senti
tout de suite d'ailleurs
on pousse ensuite raymond et les 14
autres prisonniers dans les voies de
dieu qui les attendent pour les mener
vers les cachettes prévu
quelques heures plus tard les rues de
lyon grouille de ss le succès de
l'opération a fait de raymond et lucie
aubrac de véritables bombes à
retardement
désormais toute personne de leur
entourage se trouve en danger de mort
l'uci est à présent au sein de cinq mois
[Musique]
dans les semaines qui suivent la
résistance charge de cacher les époux
aubrac
pendant qu on échafaude un plan pour les
faire sortir de france mais le 4
novembre
ils apprennent une nouvelle terrifiante
la gestapo a découvert où se trouve leur
fils et s'est mise en route vers le
vercors pour s'en emparer
l'idée qu'il pouvait être pris par les
allemands sont qu'on puisse rien y faire
était la plus épouvantable est la plus
insupportable qui soit qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait faire
aussi les membres du réseau de l'uci
font style vers le massif du vercors
afin de sauver le petit jean pierre
avant l'arrivée de la gestapo
depuis leur cachette ses parents
attendent angoissés émond a ouvert la
portière de l'autre côté et notre fils a
couru se jeter dans ses bras je ne
souhaite à personne de voir un jour son
enfant aux mains de l'ennemi
[Musique]
le 7 novembre on présente la famille
aubrac à paul rivière
l'agent responsable de leur transfert
par avion vers l'angleterre
mais les périodes de révolution lunaire
de novembre décembre et janvier passe et
chaque fois les tentatives tombe à l'eau
olry vient décide alors de coordonner
ses efforts avec ceux de l'escadron de
hugues varité finalement le 8 février un
bimoteur oddsson parvient à se poser sur
le terrain où la petite famille attend
l'uci est maintenant enceinte de neuf
mois et risquent à tout moment
d'accoucher pendant le vol
pendant les deux mois qui ont précédé
l'opération le terrain était extrêmement
sac est gelé et puis le temps a commencé
à se réchauffer et la piste est devenue
très humide l'hudson atterri à minuit
dans le champ mais lorsque le pilote
veut décoller avec les aubrac à bord
l'appareil reste immobile
la roue à bâbord s'était enlisé dans la
boue
il a fallu aller chercher de l'aide dans
les fermes allant du rock et même avec
les boeufs et les chevaux qui tirait
attaché au train d'atterrissage l'avion
ne bougeait toujours pas brûler l'avion
c'est ce que le pilote voulait faire
j'ai refusé et je lui ai dit qu'il
fallait essayer encore
on se précipite alors au village le plus
proche pour chercher de l'aide
elles se sont bientôt cinquante hommes
qui accourent vers le champ au petit
jour il faisait froid ils ont réveillé
les fermiers qui dormait au chaud avec
leur femme et celle ci leur ont dit
qu'ils devaient absolument y aller tout
de suite on ne remerciera jamais assez
ces gens pour leur aide
ça c'est des actes de résistance
après trois heures d'efforts acharnés
l'avion décolle enfin vers la liberté
[Musique]
hudson se pose en angleterre à 7 heures
du matin les aubrac sont sains et saufs
trois jours plus tard le 12 février
lucie donne naissance à leur fille
catherine o les aubrac ce mouvement
qu'on appelle la résistance n'est pas
seulement un repère historique mais une
véritable philosophie
certes il y a des moments où l'on est
obligé de se comporter en héros avec
l'aide d'une arme est l'armé principale
de la résistance française était notre
refus total de l'occupation nazie par
l'information et la solidarité
le débat sur le rôle de la résistance
dans l'issue militaire du conflit se
poursuit de nos jours je pense qu'elle a
une fonction primordiale en particulier
dans la préparation du débarquement
allié en normandie en juin 1944 les
résistants joue un rôle capital dans le
harcèlement des allemands en sabotant
leurs efforts pour renforcer les troupes
en normandie par exemple en faisant
sauter les voies de chemin de fer est-ce
que la résistance française a été
déterminante dans la victoire
je ne crois pas je dirais que ce sont
les alliés qui ont gagné la guerre
contre le nazisme
la principale contribution de la
résistance française a consisté à
préserver l'honneur de notre pays et de
ses habitants
si l'histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale nous a transmis de nombreux
témoignages sur la lutte menée par les
prisonniers alliés vous retrouver leur
liberté
le sort de milliers de leurs adversaires
allemands italiens japonais et même
finlandais reste un chapitre quelque peu
méconnu
pour autant la captivité qui l'ont vécue
n'a pas été moins destructrice que celle
vécue par n'importe quel autre
prisonnier lorsqu'un soldat jette son
arme
il est dès lors à la merci total de la
personne qui la capture tout dépend donc
de celui qui vous fait prisonnier ça
peut se passer très bien comme il peut
simplement décidé de vous descendrez
dans ce cas qui sera capable de dire un
jour qu'on vous abattu de sang froid
pour la première fois dans son histoire
la nation américaine est confrontée à
l'arrivée sur son territoire de
centaines de milliers de prisonniers de
guerre ennemis
plus de 500 mille soldats capturés au
combat vivent et travaillent dans près
de 500 camps à travers les états unis
[Musique]
chaque état de la partie continentale du
pays abritait au moins quand il y en
avait aussi en alaska
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles on a
amené ces prisonniers aux états unis et
que le président roosevelt avait réalisé
la valeur que pouvait représenter leur
main d'oeuvre
c'était une force de travail qui se
substituer en partie à celle de très
nombreux américains investis dans
l'effort de guerre
au même moment entre leur arrestation et
leur arrivée dans un corps le détenu aux
états unis les prisonniers de guerre ont
eu le temps d'être interrogé par les
officiers des services de renseignement
américains
les captifs allemands par définition
très disciplinés ne desserve
généralement pas les dents aussi
place-t-on parmi eux des appareils
d'écouté les espions afin de recueillir
l'information
à la différence des autres prisonniers
de guerre ailleurs dans le monde ce qui
arrive aux états unis sont correctement
nourris et logés comme ils reçoivent un
salaire pour le travail qu'ils
fourniront il figure en quelque sorte
parmi les soldats les plus chanceux de
la guerre à notre arrivée dans le
baraquement on a vu qu'il y avait 25
lits de camps de chaque côté tous avec
du linge des oreillers des articles de
toilette de la mousse à raser du
dentifrice tout ce qu'il fallait
ça m'a remonté le moral je me suis dit
ça s'annonce plutôt bien
on utilise également ces camps afin de
des conditio n'est les jeunes nazis et
leur inculquer à nouveau concept de
liberté
ainsi on leur distribue des livres dans
lequel le gouvernement américain
s'évertue à leur expliquer les principes
de la démocratie du pays
lorsqu'il sort travail l extérieur bon
nombre d'entre eux se mêlent à la
population civile et découvre la
philosophie de la société américaine
d'or
il regardait les jolies filles et les
femmes de leur côté se disait que ses
hommes étaient parmi les plus mignons
qu'elle n'avait jamais vu il y avait
pratiquement que des femmes au pays la
plupart des hommes étaient partis se
battre alors vous imaginez bien que ces
gars qui travaillaient torse nu
bronzé comme il était ne pouvais pas les
laisser indifférente
bien qu'en général les prisonniers
allemands mais d'une petite vie
tranquille
la plupart se languissent malgré tout de
la même manière que leurs homologues
alliés de retrouver leur liberté
le capitaine de sous marins jurgen van
den berghe figurent parmi les plus
célèbres d'entre eux officier de marine
de carrière et détenteur de la croix de
fer allemande
van den berg a déjà à son actif à 42 ans
une évasion d'accord de prisonniers en
amérique du sud
il a repris son poste au commandant du
sous marin eut cent soixante deux camps
l'après midi du 3 septembre 1942 alors
qu'ils patrouillent dans la mer des
caraïbes au large de l'amérique du sud
il tombe sur le destroyer britannique
quentin
bientôt ce sont trois navires de guerre
qui s'en prennent aux 162
[Musique]
touché par des grenades sous-marines le
bâtiment plonge à 200 m où il commence à
prendre l'eau
après six heures passées presque à la
verticale sous la surface de l'océan
le capitaine vingtaine berg ordonne à
ses hommes dans fidèles et gillet et
d'évacuer le sous marin désemparé le
u160 de s'enfonce alors rapidement vers
les profondeurs emportant dans sa coque
deux des membres de l'équipage et aux
puissants projecteurs des destroyers que
l' on repêche 48 survivants dansant dans
leur brassière de sauvetage sur les eaux
chaudes et tropicales
[Musique]
on a été surpris de voir à quel point il
était soucieux de nous sauver
il m'a fallu encore grimper à l'échelle
de corde
on était tous épuisés bien sûr j'étais
tellement content qu'on nous ait sauvé
et de m'apercevoir en même temps qu on
nous traitait avec autant de gentillesse
après avoir été interrogée sur l'île de
trinidad on dispatche l'équipage
prisonnier du us ans 60,2 à travers
plusieurs corps des états unis captif
pour la seconde fois dans le même
conflit armé le capitaine battenberg
n'en devient que plus obsédé par l'envié
de s'évader de manière identique aux
prisonniers de guerre alliés
il est du devoir de tout prisonnier
allemand selon la convention de genève
d'essayer de s'évader les camps
américains aussi les autorités
américaines qui ont compris que
l'évasion fait partie intégrante du jeu
ne punissent que rarement les fugitifs
allemands comme du reste elle ne faut
pas grand chose pour enfoncer la
sécurité des camps il est en effet pas
bien difficile de rattraper ces
prisonniers en cavale qui ont à vrai
dire aucun endroit où aller
en regardant les choses en face il n'y
avait aucune chance de sortir des états
unis que ce soit par le nord ou par le
sud
je n'ai donc jamais eu envie de courir
ce risque
malgré ce sentiment d'impuissance
pouvoir rentrer chez soi beaucoup des
prisonniers détenus dans l'étang
américain ne résiste pas au besoin
impérieux de retrouver leur liberté
le capitaine battenberg fait partie de
ces sommes après plusieurs tentatives
dans plusieurs camps on le transfère au
campo pical à la sortie de phoenix dans
l'arizona
c'est là qu'il retrouve certains membres
de son équipage du bus 162 comme valter
causeur et yoann kremer piotta qui de
leur côté la même réputation de fugitifs
peu après leur trouvaille les
sous-mariniers allemand se mettent
d'accord sur l'idée que creuser un
tunnel reste la meilleure chance de ne
pas s'éterniser dans le désert de
l'arizona
ayant découvert un angle mort qui
échappe à la surveillance des miradors
ils ont s'attaquer par équipe de 3 à 1
mètre 80 sous terre à la roche la plus
compacte qui soit une ligne électrique
tiré depuis les douches leur fournit
l'éclairage ils construisent un petit
chariot capable d'évacuer les déblais la
progression se fait au rythme d'environ
90 cm par nuit sauf lorsqu'ils tombent à
même la roche où il ne dépasse pas
généralement quelques centimètres les
allemands avaient demandé aux amériques
à la permission d'aménager un terrain de
files balle de manière à pouvoir évacuer
la terre creuse et le pharos balle est
une sorte de version allemande du volet
balle ils ont pu comme ça dispersez pas
mal de terre et heureusement pour eux le
sous-sol se trouve être de la même
composition et de la même couleur que la
surface du terrain le reste a été
répandu dans la terre de leur jardin et
une certaine quantité partie aussi dans
les cuvettes des toilettes
weinberg et ce compagnon projette de
déboucher sur un canal qui passe en
contrebas de la clôture du camp
[Musique]
à la mi décembre 1944 ils ont
pratiquement achevé leur galerie de 55
mètres de long ils ont à présent qu'une
seule envie offrir aux américains de
noël qu'ils ne seront pas prêts
d'oublier
nous sommes le 23 décembre 1944
vêtus de leur combinaison de détenus et
munis chacun d'un vieux sac élimé d'une
carte de la région 25 prisonniers de
guerre allemands s'apprêtent à traverser
le tunnel qui s'ouvre en pleine
désolation sur le désert rue de
l'arizona
tous espèrent que les permis sur
militaire de noël leur donneront une
longueur d'avancé
on attribuait une permission spéciale de
noël à une bonne partie du personnel
américain
il restait donc peu de monde sur place
pour assurer la surveillance
les allemands savaient qu'il n'y aurait
qu'un seul appel le dimanche
ils ont donc fait coïncider le moment de
leur évasion avec cette exception dans
le calendrier
ce soir là les allemands célèbrent en
même temps que noël l'avancée des
troupes allemandes dans la bataille des
ardennes on trinque on boit on casse les
bouteilles et non fini par se bagarrer
dans un vacarme épouvantable qui
détourne l'attention des sentinelles en
faction depuis leurs miradors les 25
fugitifs se sont divisés en équipes de
deux à trois hommes ils se sont
engouffrés l'un après l'autre dans le
tunnel à l'autre bout ils sortent sur
une pluie diluvienne la quasi-totalité
de la nourriture qu'ils portent sur eux
et perdu après avoir traversé à pied le
canal le plus loin possible de manière à
brouiller les pistes
le groupe se divise poursuivre des
destinations différentes
il y avait trois fugitifs qui n'aimait
pas du tout la perspective de devoir
traverser à pied cette immensité
brûlante qu'est le désert de l'arizona
il avait volé dans un véhicule de
l'armée américaine une carte de la
région et s'était aperçu que la rivière
il a été mentionné sous forme de petit
filet bleu sur la carte
elle se jetait dans le fleuve colorado
qui lui-même débouchait dans le golfe de
californie
il avait donc fabriqué dans le camp un
kayak à trois places quand ils sont
arrivés à cette fameuse rivière il a ils
ont été consternés ce n'était pas une
rivière mais une série de marie d'un
abdos évidemment tous les habitants de
la région ne savait bien mais eux
avaient pris ce filet bleu sur la carte
pour un véritable cours d'eau avec un
courant qui les transporterait
la plupart des évadés décide de fuir
érigée vers le sud en direction de la
frontière avec le mexique
si quelques-uns ne tienne le coup qu'une
nuit dans le désert de l'arizona et
finissent par se vendre d'eux mêmes à la
police locale
les camarades du us en 62 yoann kremer
et valter causeur font route avec leur
capitaine vers les montagnes du nord
[Musique]
bjoergen battenberg a dit à ses deux
compagnons qu'il s'attendait à ce qu'il
doit vivre comme des indiens il
essaierait de se trouver une grotte à
l'abri dans les montagnes c'est ici
qu'ils sont donc arrivés dans ce qu'on
appelle une inde entation de la roche dû
à l'érosion
ça leur a fait une bonne planque
ils ont placé ces gros rochers devant
que vous voyez là tout ce qu'on voulait
faire
nous ne pouvions le faire que de nuit on
ne pouvait rien se permettre le jour
parce que si un fermier avait vu
quelqu'un fureter dans les parages il
aurait aussitôt alerté le shérif
j'avais lu ça dans un livre qui
s'appelait randonnée au far west
vous ne pouvez pas comme ça traverser la
rue entrez dans un champ et planté
librement votre tante
ce n'est pas le genre des choses qu'on
fait aux états unis avant leurs
opérations
wartenberg avait prévu une cache où les
équipes de travailleurs prisonniers
laisseraient leur message ainsi que de
la nourriture pour les fugitifs
j'étais au camp numéro quatre au moment
de leur évasion
chaque jour un convoi nous conduisait à
l'arsenal il y avait là bas un atelier
de réparation automobiles ont dissimulé
la nourriture et les réserves à
l'intérieur d'une vieille carcasse de
voiture
la nouvelle de l'évasion fait la une des
journaux du pays
tout autour de phoenix arizona on se met
à rechercher activement les fugitifs la
diffusion de leurs photos dans les
quotidiens locaux visent à aider la
police ainsi qu'une population civile
nerveuse à identifier l'ennemi est
infiltré par lieu c'est van den berghe
lui même qui traduira à ces deux hommes
d'équipage
les articles de presse par lesquels ils
apprendront bientôt qu'ils sont les
derniers fugitifs à n'avoir pas été
repris sans doute grâce à la grotte dans
laquelle il se terrait survivent
[Musique]
pendant ce temps au camp de pop ical les
américains vivre un noël sous haute
tension la plupart des gardiens ont été
rappelés de leurs permissions l'armée
s'affairent à comprendre ou bien pu
passer ses 25 allemands et comment ils
se sont débrouillés pour s'enfuir
on soupçonne le creusement d'un tunnel
et l'on passe au peigne fin à
l'intérieur comme l'extérieur du camp
c'est au cours d'une patrouille le long
du canal que le soldat de première
classe
laurence higginson découvre la sortie
qu'à bouffer de la galerie creusée par
les sous mariniers pépiements j'ai eu le
réflexe de dire que ce serait amusant de
voir à quoi ressemblent et l'intérieur
du tunnel
j'ai donc dû me porter volontaire pour
aller ramper ladesou sans même savoir la
longueur que ça faisait la galerie ne
dépassaient pas une largeur des pôles et
si vous n'aimiez pas le noir complet et
bien là vous étiez servi et il a fallu
comme ça que je rende pour m'extraire de
l'autre côté
les ouvriers allemands travaillant à
l'extérieur du camp ont laissé dans la
voiture abandonnée une note pour les
trois fugitifs leur indiquant une
nouvelle cache pour leur nourriture
cependant in one kremer ne parvient pas
à la trouver leurs réserves commencent à
s'épuiser aussi décide-t-il de se
glisser jusqu'aux camps afin de
s'approvisionner avant de revenir à la
grotte
trente ou quarante prisonniers
travailler à l'extérieur du camp je
savais que si je parvenais à me mêler à
eux le jour
je rentrerai avec eux le soir et c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu entrer incognito
camp
et
mais la chance de créer mer le lâche le
23 janvier lorsqu'on le découvre au
cours d'une inspection surprise il est
resté libre pendant exactement un mois
le lendemain soir on reprend son
camarade valter causèrent weinberg reste
donc le seul et unique homme libre parmi
les 25 juridique allemand le 28 janvier
1945 transis de froid affamés et seul le
fier commandant de sous-marin quitte son
refuge de montagne et descend jusque
dans le centre ville de phoenix il passe
le long d'hôtel aux néons clignotants
qu'il aveugle dans le ciel noir de
l'arizona
la ville est infestée de gi's en
permission et ils risquent gros s'ils
louent une chambre ils dépensent les
quelques dollars qui lui reste dans un
restaurant chinois dans le salon de
l'hôtel adams
il trouve un fauteuil confortable aux
crues duquel il ne tarde pas à
s'endormir
à 1h30 du matin ce dimanche là il émerge
difficilement de son sommeil et décide
de marcher jusqu'à la gare
il était très tôt en cette fin de
janvier 1945 il faisait encore nuit
everton berg a demandé dans la rue un
ouvrier de travaux publics le chemin de
la gare de phoenix si son accent
allemand qui a mis la puce à l'oreille
de ses ouvriers
lequel a alors prévenu la police qui l'a
arrêté et van den berg a avoué son
identité
sous les acclamations de ses camarades
le capitaine fait son entrée au camp
mais après un repas copieux à l'hôpital
de pau pical on transfère van den berg
au bloc on le met au pain et à l'eau
du côté américain cette évasion a eu
d'importantes répercussions
le congrès a ordonné une enquête walter
winch elle a fait un discours
retentissant son interview radiodiffusée
à semer la pagaille dans toute la presse
nationale
on a déclaré le commandant chef fautif
est inapte à remplir ses fonctions très
peu de temps après d'ailleurs il est
obligé de prendre sa retraite plus
incapacité medica est là
la seconde guerre mondiale est enfin
terminée mais les prisonniers de guerre
allemands ne sont pas encore prêts de
revoir leur pays
on les envoie d'abord réparer par tous
il le faut les dégâts que la machine de
guerre nazie a causé ce n'est que le 16
juin 1946 que jürgen van den berghe
retrouve sa femme et ses enfants dans
son port natale de neustadt au bord de
la mer baltique enfants on savait que le
plus grand le plus riche le plus
merveilleux des pays et l amérique qui
alors n'aurait pas été aux états unis
c'était le rêve de tous les gosses
j'étais pauvre temps loin de me douter
que je découvrirai ce pays en tant que
prisonnier de guerre
mais même dans le regard d'un prisonnier
ça restait tout de même très saisissant
on se souvenait de l' envie qu'on
pouvait avoir en tant qu'enfants et on
finissait par se dire c'est tout de même
chouette d'être ici dommage que je sois
prisonniers en définitive ça quand même
été une sacrée expérience j'ai eu le
plaisir de connaître l'amérique et la
chance immense de pouvoir rentrer sains
et saufs
chez moi
[Musique]
et
à
moi
[Musique]